another thing that dr bright is not  allowed to do at the scp foundation dr  bright is not allowed anywhere near a  renaissance festival especially not with  d-class in garb the scp foundation has  some of the most high-tech equipment  you've ever seen or rather never seen  after all they're working with  unimaginable supernatural power and they  need the very cutting edge in technology  to keep all these anomalous powers  contained but of course this can make  foundation employees long for a simpler  time however that's no excuse for dr  bright to lead a band of d-classes in  medieval garb many of which by the way  are convicted killers to a local renfair  this has on multiple occasions led to  fires assaults property damage and death  some of which came from curious ren fare  attendants touching dr bright's  medallion to see if it was real  naturally the foundation isn't eager to  see this kind of history repeat itself